[Musique]
bien dans le débat sur france 24 la
finlande favorables à une adhésion sans
délai à l'otan une intégration qui ne
seraient contre personne a affirmé le
président finlandais réaction immédiate
de moscou cette entrée de la finlande à
l'otan serait assurément une menace pour
la russie qui répliquaient par des
mesures militaro technique c'est en tout
cas ce qu'a déclaré le porte parole du
kremlin dimitri peskov malgré ces
menaces russe la suède devrait également
formulé sa demande d'adhésion à l'otan
dans les prochains jours alors est ce
vraiment un tournant historique l'entrée
dans l'otan de la finlande ou encore de
la suède signerait telle la fin
définitive de leur neutralité quand on
réagir aux déclarations du kremlin un
autant élargi sera-t-il un parapluie
sécuritaire fiable face à la menace
russe finlande fin de la neutralité on
en débat avec mes invités j'ai plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés olivier schmitt
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes directeur de
recherche à l'ihp ed l institut des
hautes études de défense nationale
coauteur de guerre et paix approche et
enjeux de la sécurité de la stratégie
c'est aux presses de sciences po
bienvenue à vous en face de vous cyril a
coulé bonsoir spécialiste des pays
nordiques et ancien chercheur à
l'institut suédois des relations
internationales bienvenue à vous
également amiral alain kohl de fibres
soir ancien major général des armées
auteur de le sel et les étoiles et c'est
aux éditions favre nous avons avec nous
par skype de helsinki mari au l'opa et
nana bonsoir vous êtes député
finlandaise de la ligue verte bienvenue
à vous merci beaucoup beaucoup bonsoir
vous pouvez réagir bien sûr tout au long
de cette émission sur le hashtag débat
f24 alors n'hésitez pas sachez d'abord
pour cadrer un petit peu le débat que
l'otan aujourd'hui c'est trente membres
que l'organisation a été mise en place
par les pays signataires du traité de
l'atlantique nord c'était le 4 avril
1949 elle a créé une alliance se traiter
à créer une alliance militaire défensive
en 1957 une organisation militaire
intégrée permanente qui est créé cette
organisation était dirigé à l'époque
contre la menace que constitue et
l'union soviétique en instaurant un
couplage fort avec les états unis après
la chute de l'union soviétique en 1991
un certain nombre de pays de l'est
anciennement communistes ont sont entrés
dans l'otan dont la pologne les pays bas
et la hongrie ou encore la république
tchèque le danemark la norvège sont
également membres de l'otan donc autant
dire que la finlande et la suède avec
leur statut de neutralité font un petit
peu à 10 ans sont dans la différence en
tout cas avec cette invasion de vladimir
poutine de l'ukraine la finlande devient
maintenant favorables à une adhésion à
l'otan sans délai ont fait un point en
images avec david gilbert et on en parle
avec mes invités
le processus sera officiellement lancée
dimanche mais dans un communiqué commun
le président et la première ministre
finlandais ont clairement annoncé la fin
prochaine de près de 75 ans de
neutralité de leur pays la finlande doit
présenter sans délai une demande
d'adhésion à l'otan nous souhaitons que
les mesures encore requises au niveau
national pour entériner cette décision
soit prise rapidement dans les jours qui
viennent
une demande d'adhésion qui trouve écho
dans la population longtemps minoritaire
les partisans d'une entrée dans
l'alliance atlantique sont désormais
près de 75 % parmi les finlandais qui
ont pour la plupart changé d'avis depuis
l'invasion russe en ukraine
cela va nous apporter de la sécurité
l'otan bien sûr c'est pour cela que je
veux que l'on en fasse partie je pense
qu'on aurait déjà dû en faire partie
dans les années 90 quand c'était
possible
le processus pourrait durer de longs
mois et requiert l'unanimité des membres
de l'alliance mais pour son secrétaire
général le norvégien jens stoltenberg
l'adhésion de la finlande se déroulera
sans heurts et rapidement
côté russe la réaction est évidemment
beaucoup moins enthousiaste le porte
parole du kremlin évoque une menace
claire pour son pays qui partagent 1300
km de frontière avec la finlande et
reste évasif sur la future réaction du
pouvoir russe
tout dépendra des retombées pratiques de
ce processus et de l'avancée des
infrastructures militaires vers nos
frontières
les tensions ne sont donc pas prête de
s'apaiser d'autant que la suède
s'apprête à suivre le mouvement et
devrait annoncer sa candidature à
l'adhésion à l'otan la semaine prochaine
olivier schmitt vous qui êtes un
spécialiste de la défense a lancé cinq
millions et demi d'habitants elle
partage on l'a vu a une frontière avec
la russie de 1300 km est ce qu'on peut
dire que si elle rentre dans l'otan
c'est un tournant
du point de vue de l'alliance oui
puisqu'il ya un élargissement
supplémentaire avec a effectivement
comme vous l'avez mentionné une nouvelle
frontière bien plus longue avec la
russie qu'il s'agit de défendre puisque
c'est l'enjeu de cette adhésion c'est
que c'est il ya une défense mutuelle par
contre la finlande c'est aussi un
contributeur aux contributeurs nets de
sécurité ces forces armées sont
effectivement moderniser bien entraînés
avec un processus de défense civile qui
est rodé depuis maintenant plusieurs
décennies et qui grosso modo fait
l'admiration d'un certain nombre
d'européens donc l'adhésion de la
finlande n'est pas l'adhésion d'un pays
qui serait une espèce de passager
clandestin
pour bénéficier de la protection élargie
fournis par les européens et les états
unis en l'occurrence ce sera un
contributeur net à la sécurité de
l'alliance elle est déjà puissante
militairement c'est ce que vous dites au
regard de la taille du pays évidemment
mais c'est effectivement un contributeur
net marie online vous êtes député
finlandaise je le rappelle de la ligue
verte 76 % de la population finlandaise
est maintenant favorable à l'adhésion à
l'otan selon un dernier sondage c'est
trois fois plus que son niveau d'avant
guerre
comment l'expliquez est ce que vous avez
peur de vladimir poutine
merci pour votre invitation c'est un
grand plaisir
je dirais que la finlande comme toute
l'europe a était atterré par l'invasion
de la russe aussi en ukraine et c'est
vrai qu'on a aussi connu des guerres
contre la russie malheureusement il ya
longtemps mais mr on oublie pas et je
crois que les finnois les finlandais ont
raison et on doit réagir maintenant
mais il faut aussi dire que la finlande
est un membre actif de l'union
européenne depuis presque trente ans
donc en fait à la finlande ne se définit
plus comme un pays neutre depuis
longtemps mais est ce qu'il ya une peur
de la divers poutine aujourd'hui qui
expliqueraient ce revirement tout de
même
et je crois comme tous les européennes
on a peur de la guerre bien sûr
mais je dirais aussi que la plante veut
décider sur
son avenir et c'est ce qu'on appelle
maintenant
cyril coulet ce que c'est un tournant
pour vous qui êtes spécialiste justement
de ces pays là ton en politique
sécuritaire voire culturelles alors
c'est très clairement pour la suède un
tournant c'est assez sur la suède parce
que pour la ci n'a pas encore fait
officiellement sa demande mais qu'ils
devraient le faire également fin dans
les prochains en tout cas elle est
entraînée par dans ce processus par la
finlande et les neutralité suédoises et
finlandaises ne sont pas de même nature
je pense que la neutralité fernandez a
beaucoup et est la résultante justement
de son environnement stratégique
elle est plus récente s'est construite
dans la relation avec l'urss pendant la
guerre froide m a été suédoise elle est
plus ancienne elle se définit autrement
et elle a fait l'objet d'une
appropriation politique en interne ils
m'ont considère qu'elle avait traité
suédoise avait trois phases une phase
qui a été le moment où la social
démocratie a construit un consensus
politique autour de du soutien au
développement d'une industrie de défense
et de capacités militaires au cours des
années 20 des années 30 une deuxième
phase qui a été une phase prises par les
diplomates avec un rôle très actif une
promotion de la suède à l'image
internationale et on pense à la figure
de da gama seul qui était secrétaire
général des nations unies et une
troisième phase qui était très
idéologique porté par olof palme dans
les années 70 et 80 et qui fait que le
rapport qu'ont les suédois à la question
de l'alliance militaire n'était pas du
même ordre que celui qu'ont les
finlandais et je pense que en
l'occurrence la finlande aujourd'hui et
est une force motrice dans l'évolution
d'apposition suédoise amiral à la colle
de pièces que c'est une bonne idée la
fin de la neutralité finlandaise
alors la fin de la neutralité
finlandaises et suédoises probable et
suédoises je dirais c'est leur affaire
moi je dirais qu on montre en regardant
la carte que vous avez montré
stratégiquement les russes ont perdu
sont bouclés en mer noire et sont
bouclés en mer baltique ils ont perdu
l'accès aux mers chaudes qui depuis
pierre legrand et leur obsession là
c'est le premier point deuxième point là
on a deux pays qui sont des pays
guerrier leur histoire le montre qui
pour la finlande est en état de
surveillance et que pour la suède a
développé un outil militaire cohérent
avec des capacités industrielles donc
militairement malgré la petitesse de
leur population 5 millions et 10
millions je crois on a un atout
considérable pour l'otan alors le reste
après se discute paradoxe est que
poutine tais toi t il a encore raté la
faire avec les pays les pays bas et la
finlande et la suède la suède a déjà
préparé était déjà en guerre avec les
risques les russes survoler son espace
aérien faisait dans d intrusion dans son
espace maritime
et pour ceux qui ne le savent pas l'a16
a déjà dispatcher ses états majors des
armées loin de stockholm alors que dans
tous les pays s'est concentré à paris à
londres à washington dc auquel une sorte
de préparation les suédois sont préparés
c'est de nature différente c'est un plus
pour l'alliance atlantique ça mauvais
coup pour les russes bien sûr et là on a
deux pays qui vont nous apporter quelque
chose si l'on se fait purement vos plans
militaire et où plan stratégique comme
je l'indiquais les deux narines de
churchill dont l'ours russe qui sent le
bosphore à l'e3 baltes sont bouchées
olivier schmitt de son côté le
secrétaire général de l'alliance à jens
stoltenberg a déjà assuré aujourd'hui
que la finlande si la finlande décidé de
postuler âge le site elle serait
chaleureusement accueilli au sein de
l'otan mais il faut quand même expliquer
aux téléspectateurs que ça va pas se
faire en quelques jours donc là il ya
une intention ensuite il y aura une
vraie formulation d'adhésion normalement
ce week-end concrètement qu'est ce que
ça veut dire d'abord est-ce qu'il va y
avoir des troupes justement sur les sols
suédois et finlandais des troupes de
l'otan est ce que ça veut dire qu'il y
aura des exercices en mer baltique en ce
qui concerne l'article 5 qui est
l'article donc justement de solidarité
des différents membres de l'otan quand
peut-il s'appliquer à ces pays raconté
dans un tout petit peu le calendrier
alors il ya effectivement plusieurs
dimensions et la première dimension qui
est qui et l'adhésion à l'alliance le
l'alliance l'otan a mis en place un
processus qui est maintenant bien rodée
qui est donc en fait qui s'appelle le
plan d'adhésion à l'alliance atlantique
c'est le cédant 2 dans le nom est en
fait l'idée c'est d'avoir un dialogue
avec les pays candidats pour les
conseiller sur la structuration de leurs
forces armées l'organisation de leurs
relations civilo-militaires aussi
puisqu'il s'agit pas d'avoir en fait des
dictatures militaires qui rejoint de
l'otan lise les conseillers sur la
manière de s'intégrer et de de
s'approprier les procédures et les
manières de faire de l'alliance
atlantique qui permettent en fait le
travail en collaboration sauve au dos ça
prend combien de temps cela la finlande
très français
pour la finlande et la suède ça peut
être relativement rapide parce que ça
voudrait dire qu'il ya une procédure un
peu exprès c'est à dire qu'elle est pas
exprès c'est à dire que ce sont des pays
qui en fait ont déjà les standards la
suède va participer aux opérations de
l'otan en afghanistan ils connaissent
les procédures ils sont déjà insérés la
finlande 2 dispose de matériel militaire
américain ce qui suppose aussi en
général une formation commune dont on en
fait tout un ensemble de procédures sont
déjà maîtrisé par ces pays on n'est plus
du tout dans la situation où il
s'agissait de transformer des pays qui
étaient membres du pacte de varsovie en
membres de l'otan oui mais même en 1997
il me semble qu'il avait pris quand même
moins 18 mois pour les pays baltes la
gare
fallait les transformer en qu'elle
voudrait pas l'air tout à fait d'accord
amiral
il ya une énième procédure expresse à ce
vous dites nous expliquer pour le public
la différence entre l'intégration à
l'union européenne et l'intégration le
temps oui alors là les deux procédures
l'intégration à l'otan charlie sheen au
bout de la table par le représentant
américain et à partir du moment où il a
dit oui tout le monde exécute et là ça
peut être tueur est moins d'un an
surtout quand on vient de vous venez de
le dire avec des pays qui sont déjà
préparées l'adhésion à l'union
européenne c'est une batterie de
critères l'état de droit la liberté la
bonne gouvernance et là on met des mois
et des mois et des mois donc ça veut
dire un an à peu près pour la finlande
et la suède va être même un petit peu
plus court mais en gros entre 9 et 18
mois je serai pas sûr c'est une première
mais on va regarder d'ailleurs le tweet
du président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky qui a réagi bien sûr avec
satisfaction il a même félicité le
président finlandais lors d'un échange
téléphonique c'est ce qu'il a indiqué
dans son tout est un vous le voyez ici
on voit bien tout de même ce soutien du
président ukrainien oleg schultz le
chancelier allemand a également félicité
le président finlandais donc on voit
effectivement qu'il ya une sorte de bloc
qui est en train de se constituer marie
all hope heinen le président finlandais
lui était plutôt favorable au début en
tout cas un dialogue avec la russie
comment est-ce que vous réagissez aux
propos du kremlin quand ils disent
justement que c'est une menace pour la
russie que cette demande de l'entrée
dans l'otan et qu' il pourrait répliquer
par des mesures militaro et technique
c'est ce qu'a déclaré en tout cas à
dmitri peskov
et merci je dirais que la finlande en
tout cas de menace à personne
donc c'est juste que nous on veut
décider comment on organise la défense
comme la majorité des pays de l'union
européenne font partie à l'otan je pense
que c'est vraiment quand même une
décision comme
on pourrait faire maintenant mais aux
décisions comme aurait dû père avant et
un peu comment on a parlait déjà la
finlande a
fait déjà partie aux exercices commune
de l'otan depuis longtemps et finlande
dont on a parlé de l'option l'otan pour
longtemps donc
c'est quand même pour vous c'est que
c'est presque naturel en fait une sorte
de filtre naturel exactement circulation
ont fait un peu d'histoire justement le
pays alors je parle de la finlande
recettes fois c'était une province russe
d'après ce que j'ai lu entre 1809 et
1917 dont pratiquement 100 ans une
province russe envahi par l'urss en 1939
on appelle ça la guerre d'hiver
manifestement la guerre d'hiver ça
continue ça constitue le mythe fondateur
de la nation finlandaise un traité dont
qui avait été signé en 1940 très des
avances désavantageux pour la finlande
donc à écouter mario lopez non non c'est
même étonnant qu'ils aient attendu aussi
longtemps alors
oui et non
il ya effectivement là la première
guerre d'hiver il ya la guerre de
continuation s'il faut pas oublier que
les finlandais sont allés combattre
parfois à proximité des troupes
allemandes 1 en urss et c'est justement
de là que vient en définitive la
neutralité finlandaise c'est la
neutralité talent days ça a été le moyen
d'éviter que la finlande qui était un
pays qui était lié à l'urss par un
traité de coopération et d'amitié
mutuelles ne se retrouvent pas intégré
dans le bloc de l'europe de l'est dans
le bloc des pays satellites et puisque
c'est est ce qu'il est et à harmoniser
finalement par l'union soviétique à
l'époque cette neutralité
concrètement ça a été effectivement la
seule option pour sortir de l'emprise
soviétique
obtenir notamment la restitution de la
base de porc kalla qui se trouvait au
large des think i retrouver une forme de
souveraineté mais une souveraineté
limitée très clairement jusqu'à la fin
de l'urss la vie politique finlandaise
était toujours sous l'observation de son
voisin soviétique et un certain nombre
d'expressions ne pouvait pas avoir lieu
comme elles avaient lieu dans son dans
son voisin suédois par exemple amiral à
la colle de l'application les risques
justement qu'il prenne face à moscou en
décidant d'adhérer à l'otan lorsqu'on
entend les menaces de dmitri peskov
je pense pas qu'ils prennent de grands
risques en faites et l'analyse du
président finlandais me paraît tout à
fait justifiée prête pas beaucoup de
risques parce que comme vous l'avez
rappelé madame la de la finlande
n'attaque personne il se défend plutôt
depuis depuis des années qu'elle le
prenne comme une attaque évidemment oui
mais puis sur sa formule à celle engagée
sur bien obligé de dire et quand on voit
les paroles de rétorsion je veux dire
d'un torsion militaro-technique ça ne
veut strictement rien ne veut rien dire
dans le langage militaire rien dire du
tout ça veut dire que ils sont un peu
dans le désarroi les russes alors leur
opération a échoué à finlande alors
après on peut juger au plan stratégique
de tout ce qu'on veut les pays
scandinaves le fait sable et la finlande
a fait un choix pour moi qu'est bon qui
va renforcer sa sécurité
est-ce qu'elle va pas être vulnérable le
temps que tout ça se met en place non
pas du tout pas du tout l'autre l'otan
intervient en quelques minutes si ce
pôle mais là elle n'appartient pas
encore à l'otan tombé entre le délai
justement de demandes et le moment
rentrera dans l'otan est ce qu'elle
n'est pas en position de l'une à l'autre
c'est là aussi une fois que la finlande
à intégrer l'otan son territoire
relèvera l'article 5 qui n'est pas aussi
ont des gens comme dit d'ailleurs dans
les grandes dans les grandes discussions
hélas ce moment là pas un centimètre
carré de la finlande pour être attaqués
sans que l'alliance ne se sente ac et ça
c'est quand elle sera rentré quand elle
se rend triste mais à l'heure actuelle
on voit bien en cas de l'ukraine qui dit
non l'union européenne ni dans le temps
que les occidentaux entre guillemets ont
considéré qu'il y avait une atteinte
inadmissible à partir de mon monde ou
voulant partir dans le combat s'il a
voulu montrer que vous l'attaquez toute
l'ukraine donc moi je crois qu'en plus
et je sais ce que vous disiez monsieur
nous on l'a on a là deux armées qui sont
entraînants entraînés qui sont capables
de se battre et qui connaissent déjà les
procédures je rappellerai que la suède a
envoyé en 2003 pour une opération de
l'union européenne qui se plaît artemis
en ituri c'est au congo à peu près 60
forces spéciales à ya quand même un
entraînement qui et qui fait qu' on
n'est pas dans un monde inconnu marie o
loughlin est ce que cette nouvelle
dépendance à l'égard des états unis
posent question
bon je croque et je pense que la
finlande
et est vraiment allié avec l'union
européenne
sur tout mais le temps c'est que c'est
les états unis
pardonnez-moi bruit puis aussi aussi
mais on a besoin de l'europe l'effort
aussi et j'ai comporte aussi la france
fait beaucoup de travail avec ambition
pour une europe commune et pour les
valeurs européennes
c'est important aussi et on va
contribuer nous nous aussi la finlande
pour
commandes au salon barça n'est pas ça
n'est plus vraiment un sujet en finlande
justement que de se dire qu'on va
bénéficier d'un parapluie malgré tout il
ya trente membres mais on sait très bien
que ce sont les américains qui domine
l'otan ce n'est pas un sujet oui oui les
américains aussi sont importants des est
vraiment oui mais au nom de notre
coopération c'est avec les américains et
aussi avec le royaume-uni donc la
finlande le royaume-uni ont signé hier
les gueulards à quoi faire alors
justement boris johnson lui il est passé
vous voir il est allé en finlande et en
suède pour signer avec vous cet accord
de sécurité ça aussi c'est un petit peu
historique on va l'écouter oui boris
johnson
la finlande est bien sûr
traditionnellement neutres mais il
s'agit de formaliser de clarifier
quelque chose qui doit être explicite
dans le contexte d'aujourd'hui explique
etienne context of today à savoir qu'en
cas d' attaque contre l'un de nous tous
nous soutiendront mutuellement sur
demande ce point à prendre a promu west
oui geste mais est ce que ça veut dire
que justement la grande bretagne peut
aider la suède et la finlande pendant ce
moment un peu de flottement avant
justement qu'il soit véritablement
intégré alors il ya noté il ya
effectivement et c'est une déclaration
très claire du premier ministre
britannique qui est aussi lié à un
besoin politique britannique de montrer
qu'ils sont des contributeurs nets à la
sécurité européenne après le break site
mais qui s'inscrit dans un contexte plus
large de je n'imagine pas des pays
membres de l'otan qui resterait passif
devant une attaque d'un pays comme la
finlande du lasso ou la suède alors
qu'il semble justement dans le processus
d'adhésion la crédibilité politique de
la garantie collective en prendrait
immédiatement un coup droit en fait même
si juridiquement ce sont deux pays qui
vont rejoindre l'otan dans une
temporalité qui reste à définir
précisément mais qui vont rejoindre
l'otan prochainement politiquement
defacto il y a déjà une forme de
garanties de sécurité qui élargit à
partir du moment où tout le monde est
d'accord sur le sur le processus c'est
aussi pour ça que la russie réagi
vivement ils ont bien compris
l'importance de la dimension politique
assez coulé l'otan donc encore élargie
est ce que ça paraît être un parapluie
fiables alors que les états unis sont
quand même dans un questionnement
d'interventionnisme dans le monde sert
qu'on est plus dans quelque chose qui
ressemble à un retrait et puis et puis
surtout est ce qu'il n'ya pas une sorte
d'ironie de l'histoire on parle
effectivement de finlandisation de
l'ukraine avant que vladimir poutine
envahissent l'ukraine en citant vraiment
la fin d'emploi exemple pour justement
l'appliquer à l'ukraine et aujourd'hui
on se retrouve avec une finlande qui va
rentrer dans l'otan face est très
clairement effectivement on voit bien
que la notion de sécurité collective est
en train d'évoluer là ce que ce qu'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure sur le passé la
neutralité apparaissait pendant un temps
comme étant une garantie de sécurité que
l'appartenance à une alliance militaire
pouvait ne pas offrir aujourd'hui
la guerre en ukraine apporte au
contraire
l'idée que l'appartenance à une alliance
militaire est une garantie de sécurité
bien plus importante que ne le serait en
définitive la neutralité et ça c'est un
renversement de perspective qui est
d'autant plus frappant effectivement
lorsqu'on considère l'exemple de la
finlande ont parlé en plus de
effectivement de mort cérébrale de
l'otan il n'y a pas si longtemps olivier
schmitt et et je leur pose cette
question parce que s qu'effectivement
l'otan ait les reins suffisamment
solides si je puis dire on parlait d'une
mort cérébrale il ya à peine un nom il
me semble qu emmanuel macron dans
l'année qui célèbre aujourd'hui on
savait aussi que les états unis étaient
en train de se retirer du monde on a vu
avec le retrait d'afghanistan est ce que
ça va rester en s'élargissant de plus en
plus à ce que l'otan va rester un
parapluie fiable face à la menace russe
la plupart des alliés y croit
manifestement le président américain joe
biden a lui même eu des mots très forts
sur le fait que aucun centimètre carré
de l'otan ne resterait pas défendu donc
ça veut dire que l'engagement américain
il doit tout de même continué à être
très clair alors il faut jouer en 2024
très franchement en fonction du
président américain qui sera élu c'est
la précision aux cibles joe biden a
l'air assez activement engagés bien sûr
donald mais ça c'est ça l'histoire de
l'alliance enfin fondamentalement depuis
1949 c'est l'histoire de l'alliance
quelle est la crédibilité de la garantie
américaine la réponse française a été on
va quand même prendre nos propres
mesures de sécurité en
on se dotant d'une arme de dissuasion
que nous contrôlons nous-mêmes qui est
la dissuasion nucléaire parce que on a
toujours eu ce doute
certains alliés n'ont absolument pas le
doute voilà c'est donc je ne peux pas
vous dire ce qui va se passer en 2024
mais il ya des perceptions différentes
de l'engagement américain là il ya aussi
un chiffre qui est important c'est que
il ya ainsi le temps qu'ils qu'à
quelques années à essayer de chiffrer la
contribution des états unis à la
sécurité européenne tout compris pas
seulement dans l'otan mais tout compris
en gros c'est entre 180 et 250 milliards
de dollars par an que les états unis des
dépenses de différentes manières enfin
il renégocie
que je veux dire c'est que si les
américains se retiraient d'un seul
couple l'otan pour avoir le même degré
de sécurité il faudrait que les états
membres les états européens de l'otan
dépenses collectivement entre 180
milliards et 250 milliards de dollars
supplémentaires c'est un effort
financier que je pense nous ferons
absolument pas prêt à faire amiral à
l'apple ii le suis donc ça veut dire
pour s'en remettre même aux états unis
donc au joe biden a l'air effectivement
d'être dans ce couplage avec l'europe
mais ça n'est pas évident peut-être que
justement un président républicain ne
sera pas du tout dans cette veine là on
l'a vu avec donald trump qui en fait est
d'ailleurs joe biden avait repris
demandé aux européens de mettre beaucoup
plus au jour de la défense je crois pas
du tout aux déclarations de retrait qui
sont épisodiques jeu les états aux
étages et visage vous dit elles
reviennent elles reviennent de façon
suivie sur idole ou episode i ou
cycliques faut se rappeler qu'au plan
strictement militaire le budget du
pentagone ces 700 milliards $ c'est
largement une fois et demie le budget de
la france rien que le budget militaire
du pentagone des et à une écrasante
supériorité militaire qui se décline pas
forcément plan politique puisque les
valeurs occidentales sont pas très bien
reconnue dans le monde donc là moi je
crois qu'il est aucune crainte
militaires à avoir là-dessus je rappelle
qu'il ya trois mois le est pas le
militaire sur le politique
je crois dépend d'une décision politique
donc lorsque je commence à dire que une
décision politique peut s'appeler sur un
outil militaire fort il ya trois mois à
peu près l'otan déployées 20 à 30000
personnes dans dans le nord de la mer du
nord la baltique pour des exercices qui
était prévu de l'entente
les russes étaient avertis
russe en face était hétéro si ça fait
partie du parti des choses mais match
qui
peut être pas le temps de rebondir sur
bordeaux bien sûr à les y
brille johnson il est dans une position
délicate il faut qu ils manoeuvrent en
interne vis-à-vis des etats-unis et
vis-à-vis de l'europe donc il a un
créneau qui l'utilisent politique manqué
de dire flamberge au vent je vais
défendre la finlande s'il se passe
quelque chose de dire ça change rien à
rien en pratique pas ce qu'il se passe
quelque chose en finlande les pays de
l'otan miron et la france ira avec la
même vitesse que le royaume est en
revanche en revanche dit me permettre
d'aller au bout de la réflexion sur la
finlande je crois que c'est la france
qui a perdu parce que depuis le général
de gaulle nous avions dans la guerre
froide un espace de manoeuvre entre les
deux blocs que deux avions en partie
conservée jusqu'à jusqu'à l'afghanistan
au gros et puis maintenant on voit bien
que cet espace de manoeuvre politique il
a un peu disparu nous pays européens bon
maintenant ils vont vers washington tout
le temps alors que nous n'avions jédir
une position qui était qui permettait de
sa douche et 2 contres et entend bien
comment vous l'expliquer parce qu
emmanuel macron lui met beaucoup en
avant une défense européenne les
personnes en vie personne n'en veut
défense européenne une armée européenne
qui la commandent un général français
pourquoi pas c'est la france le feu
nucléaire health acceptable pour les
vins chill autre nom
est ce que vous pouvez rebondir mario
lopez est ce que est ce que vous pour
vous quoi qu'il arrive le temps sera
fiable un parapluie fiable de sécurité
face à la menace russe
oui est ce que le parapluie américain de
l'otan est ce que l'otan reste un mode
de sécurité fiable pour vous c'est à
dire vous ne mettez pas en doute l'otan
son efficacité
il faut y travailler pour la démocratie
tous les jours donc on ne sait jamais ce
qui va arriver mais je crois que oui ça
va rester l europe doit définir aussi
les conditions d'un an elle la
responsable responsabilité sera mise en
oeuvre avant que ça que nous on doit
aussi travailler pour leur aurait aidé
pour définir comment l'europe sera plus
fort aussi en défense aussi et c'est ce
qu'on a
c'est que vous êtes partisan d'une
défense européenne plus forte
aussi ça oui bah oui on en a besoin en
europe les forts aussi un défense et
c'est ce que l'allemagne un pet a déjà
fait donc vous y croyez contrairement
l'amiral
à une défense européenne plus forte
oui on a un petit problème de liaison
ursula von der leyen en tout cas la
présidente de la commission était en
visite au japon et à l'estiment elle que
la russie est devenue la menace la plus
directe à l'ordre mondial on va
l'écouter
la russie est aujourd'hui la menace la
plus directe pour l'ordre mondial avec
la guerre barbare contre l'ukraine mais
aussi son pacte inquiétant avec la chine
qui entraîne de nouvelles relations
internationales très arbitraire
cyril coulet donc on disait la de russie
de vladimir poutine est en train de
redéfinir totalement le périmètre de la
sécurité en europe oui ça repose effet
que dire cela von der leyen y compris au
japon mais je crois que c'est ce que
l'on dit autour de ce plateau à savoir
que actuellement on commence à repenser
autrement aussi la sécurité et que la
sécurité européenne de toute façon elle
ne peut pas s'affranchir de son appui
américain c'est très compliqué nos
systèmes sont très intégrés on a peu
parlé mais de toute façon la finlande la
suède sont entrés depuis le début des
années 90 dans dans une intégration
technique militaires avec les forces
de l'otan donc c'est pas en soi une
révolution technique c'est vraiment une
révolution dans la manière de se penser
de penser son rap solution politique
tout de même alors pour la finlande peut
être un peu moins je le redis je pense
que pour la suède pour le coup c'est
clairement une vraie révolution
parce que ce pays a investi c'est la
neutralité autrement que c'était pas que
le produit de son environnement
international c'était aussi le produit
de cette société et qui à un moment
donné c'est la façon dont on se définit
vis-à-vis des autres contre on se pense
et on projette son image par rapport au
monde ce que disait l'amiral est assez
juste je me souviens des officiers
suédois qui avait la larme à l'oeil nous
expliquer comment il était ému de voir
les sous marins nucléaires lanceurs
d'engins français quitter la rade de
brest se disant ben on aurait dû avoir
la même chose aujourd'hui clairement les
choses ne se pose plus en ces termes là
donc la façon dont on pense la sécurité
collective change et je pense que
finalement même nous français notre
cadre de pensée sur la sécurité
collective à être bousculés est impacté
par la guerre en ukraine c'est à dire
qu'il faut une vision veut dire qu'ils
ne soient plus nationale amiral
justement de la sécurité là vous parlez
de neutralité de la suède s'est terminée
la neutralité ce président-là la
neutralité a fait long feu mais tout le
monde le sait fait long feu de plus
depuis longtemps tout le monde le sait
et donc c'est pas le sujet le sujet
comme vous l'indiquez c'est de savoir
sur quelle organisation de sécurité
globale on va se reposer désormais parce
que là ça met en jeu également le rôle
de l'eau et du l'europe de membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité qui
sont issus de la deuxième guerre
mondiale en est quand même 77 ans après
et donc à peut-être falloir redéfinir le
périmètre
la mission de l'onu de façon acceptable
par les autres pays donc là on est
rentré dans un grand maelström où je
reviens un peu sur petit façon
caricaturale sur la défense européenne
parce que pendant vingt ans j'ai essayé
de construire la défense européenne à
mon petit niveau avec les partenaires
allemands anglais et autres et alors non
mais je veux dire c'était compliqué
c'est pas compliqué techniquement on
travaille ensemble tous les jours mais
est ce qu'aujourd'hui n'est pas une
volonté politique plus forte alors
justement il ya un changement alors dans
la digue dans les camps les eaux quand
les européens on perd ensemble il se
resserre
ils sont déjà resserré au plan
économique au plan énergétique organise
à faire l'environnement et donc on est
dans le moment il faudrait que
malheureusement la peur continue un tout
petit peu pour voir progresser mais on
est quand même dans dans un dispositif
où guy pascal interviews des éléments
économiques l'économie américaine a
envie d'arriver l'industrie américaine a
envie d'arriver on doit bien là cette
produit ses propres armement elle
produit ces sous marins le produit six
avions de combat le produit presque
toutes les scènes la suède un peu comme
nous il va bien falloir qu'un jour on
s'entende et on va on va y arriver donc
vous parler d'une entente plus
militaro-industriel s'en va c'est une
des bases tenais pas à partir du moment
où on s'entend sur le terrain militaro
industriel car les deux sont
terriblement connectés on peut et on
voit bien que sans faire d'anti
américanisme primaire l'idée des
américains est temps que ce
plafond de peur qui est entretenue on va
vous protéger les f-35 harris vais m'en
suis d'ailleurs les équipements
américains arrivent et là c'est pour
l'industrie américaine
bats pour l'industrie européenne quels
sont les obstacles ont fait de
rapprochement entre eux est justement
ces différentes industries militaires
européennes allaient les obstacles sont
l'industrie militaire et les mêlées
consanguine de la capacité unitaire on
peut pas s'en séparer on peut pas avoir
des militaires dans un pays une
industrie dans l'autre donc il faut que
chacun soit capable de alors après on
peut travailler en coopération sur des
sujets qui sont peu sensibles le fuji
les régates etc il ya des sujets
essentiels et si on regarde bien la
position de la france sur ces sujets
essentiels qui sont essentiellement
autour de la dissuasion les sous marins
nucléaires lanceurs d'engins sous marin
nucléaire d'attaqué porte avions à
propulsion nucléaire etc et pas de
coopération possibles de même que les
allemands n'ont pas très envie je
travaillais à sécher airbus n'ont pas
très envie d'être à égalité avec la
france dans le domaine industriel
considère que c'est la plus grande
puissance économique et industriel
d'europe donc le challenge est un petit
peu difficile et avec les anglais on
arriverait bien un accord mais on n'a
pas les mêmes objectifs stratégiques on
n'a pas fait il avait l'aviation
européenne alors que naturellement après
après le concorde après le jaguar après
le plus bas je parle pour les
techniciens on aurait dû faire une
industrie franco britannique mais c'est
trop tard maintenant c'est trop tard
j'attends donc aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
en fait l'un quand on parle de défense
européenne faut distinguer ce qui relève
effectivement la défense militaire qui
va rester structurellement de toute
façon principalement l'otan tant que les
états unis seront la principale garantie
de sécurité mais ce qui relève aussi de
toutes les dimensions économiques
juridiques
diplomatique et qui en fait sont des
instruments dont dispose l'union
européenne dont ne disposent pas l'otan
c'est pas l'otan qui capable d'imposer
des sanctions économiques à la russie
mais quand on doit gérer la russie il ya
effectivement à la fois la dimension
militaire mais il ya une dimension
économique et dimension diplomatique et
c'est cette articulation des différentes
organisations de sécurité qui est en
train d'émerger est ce qu'on voyait il
ya encore vingt 20 ans ou même les états
unis un certain nombre de pays européens
disaient et surtout pas surtout pas
l'union européenne aucune compétence
dans le domaine parce que ça va être en
concurrence avec l'otan ce discours-là
de la concurrence des deux organisations
en fait n'existe plus aujourd'hui en
pratique à bruxelles il ya des formes de
convergence qui sont en train d'émerger
parce que tous les états membres se sont
rendus compte que l'otan avait un
avantage comparatif qui était son
intégration dans le domaine militaire
que l'union européenne avec beaucoup
d'avantagés comparatifs qui était en
fait la possibilité de jouer sur tout un
ensemble de levier politico économiques
dont dispose pas l'otan et ses plus
l'articulation entre les deux qu'il
s'agit trouver sachant que le le nombre
de membres de l'union européenne qui
sont aussi membres de l'otan est quand
même assez substantiel donc ça veut dire
qu'il y aura une nouvelle architecture
sécuritaire européenne avec donc cette
intégration de la suède et de la
finlande dans l'otan vous êtes d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit oui c'est
assez probable alors ensuite on va y
avoir aussi une concurrence et d'une
sorte de course aux armements dans
laquelle tous les pays sont en train de
s'engouffrer alors il va y avoir du
réarmement ensuite est ce que ce sera
une course aux armements ça va dépendre
des blocs un jeu ce que disait en tout
cas
mais mes collègues autour du plateau est
très juste ce qui fait en sociologie
politique le groupe avant les valeurs
communes c'est en fait la frontière on
définit d'abord contre eux qui n'est pas
à l'intérieur aujourd'hui ce qui est en
train de se faire c'est ça on est en
train de redéfinir la frontière contre
eux qui on est qui est à l'extérieur qui
est à l'intérieur et la menace
aujourd'hui salle a menacé la russie la
russie la guerre en ukraine est un
catalyseur de cette évolution
clairement ça va appeler à une
recomposition d'un certain nombre de
questions mais pourquoi pas la
constitution d'une base européenne et
technologies de défense en a longtemps
parlé il ya eu des avancées mais il ya
aussi eu des réticences a été évoquée
très justement clairement aujourd'hui
on se trouve un pour moi quand même
c'est un vrai point de bascule
l'interrogation qui reste pas pour l'un
finlande mais plus pour la suède c'est
patent savoir comment l'otan est en
capacité d'accepter un nouveau membre
c'est comment la société en capacité
comment les parlementaires peuvent voter
en fait
c'est cette prise de conscience d'un
changement de son rapport en fait au
monde
clairement la suède s'est pensé comme un
exemple assez pensé comme étant unique
et ses pensées comme étant extérieur un
peu à cet ensemble de sécurité européen
quand bien même elles lui appartenaient
même d'un par la guerre froide où elle
avait déjà en fait des standards otan
qui équipaient ces appareils notamment
militaires
donc si vous surprend en fait les
incapacités finalement des suédois à
renoncer à quelque chose dont il avait
fait une identité on a parlé de la
france on parle de la suède c'est ce
parallèle a été fait je suis assez
d'accord ça ne m'a toujours frappé en
fait ce sont les suédois me semble être
un peu nous nos cousins du nord dans le
rapport en fait à la souveraineté à la
question de l'heure la projection de
leur image au monde c'est quelque chose
qui est très loin d'être indifférent et
là on est sur un pour moi un vrai
basculement parce que la rule la guerre
en russe en ukraine est un catalyseur de
changement caméra alors je prends juste
revenir sur le mode course aux armements
que vous avez évoquées en tout cas moi
je dis les années soit les années 90
c'était l'euphorie des relations
internationales chute des budgets
consacrés à la défense est là a
manifestement on va j'ai pas une course
aux armements ça veut dire que le reste
du monde se réarment depuis des années
et on n'a pas voulu voir jeu donner un
exemple comme je l'amiral la chine
construit tous les quatre ans
l'équivalent de la flotte française qui
est la première en europe on n'a pas
parlé de l'ennemi chinois ne parlent que
de la menace russe non mais je veux dire
tous les pays la turquie la chine
l'algérie a un budget militaire
considérable et d'où on a désarmé et
bien les fameux bisounours on n'a pas
voulu voir les menaces dans la surtout
pas voulu voir que tous les autres
termes et on était le seul îlot à être
continûment désarmé en europe l'europe
l'europe occidentale
marie au l'open une réaction peut-être
justement sur ce fait que tout le monde
réarme aujourd'hui et qu'est-ce que ça
provoque chez vous dans un pays où
justement qui était notre donc on dit
plutôt pacifiste même si effectivement
vous aviez une rare mais parce que
justement un grand leader qui vous était
pas pacifisme
merci je dirais carnet lequel apple ne
se définit depuis longtemps comme un
pays neutre up mais ce même mais un pays
qui n'était pas un militairement ali
alliés et je pense que la guerre
d'agression lancé par la russie a fait
disparaître la fois la basse d'un autre
mondial international fondé sur les
règles et maintenant ce qu'on doit faire
il faut renforcer
l'ordre mondial des règles et hippo
vraiment
travailler pour la paix ce qu'on doit
faire donc ça veut dire en fait mettre
en place des organisations sécuritaire
pour obtenir la paix au final c'est ça
amiral en fait la solution auj appareil
a pas de solution sinon la fois des
chercheurs le retrouver la difficulté
c'est de marcher ensemble je pense que
maintenant marche de plus en plus
ensemble on va on va y arriver mais il
faut pas oublier qu'il ya des choses le
départ de la france l'allemagne et le
royaume-uni la france et le royaume-uni
ont un système politico militaire de
décision ultra rapide hier le chef de
gouvernement le chef d'état décide de
l'envoi des forces et le parlement
approuve ou désapprouvent après et les
armées britannique et française sont
faites pour se projeter pour la
politique française brut et l'armée
allemande était dans mes parts
commentaire la chancelière le chancelier
maintenant n'a pas l'emploi de l'armée
le ministre n'a pas l'emploi de l'armée
y a pas un chef d'état major des armées
déjà ramassé le legs de 1945 géline
voilà et donc c'est armé avait pour
mission de défendre le territoire dow
est conceptuellement n'a parlé de
paradigme eu tout à l'heure mais les
d'armé qui a été fait pour protéger le
territoire allemand quand on l'engagé en
bosnie il a fallu que la cour
constitutionnelle
accepte que des soldats allemands clique
de saône allemand alors tout ça avance
c'était quatre ans donc les allemands
doivent aussi faire fléchir un peu la
révolution ils sont partis sont peu
partout il a fallu trente ans pour qu'on
en trouve en afghanistan au mali
excellent avec une accélération en ce
moment
enfin je je pense que l'annoncent de
l'augmentation du budget de la défense
enfin il ya cinq ans qui concourait dit
tous les allemands se tirer d'un seul
coup sans miller de revendre leur
défense personne ne l'aurait cru et je
pense que les allemands eux mêmes n'y
aurait absolument pas cru donc
effectivement on a parlé de l'invasion
qui est un catalyseur mais fait que le
24 février change fondamentalement la
donne dans l'articulation de sécurité
européenne c'est très net s'est écoulé à
je pense qu'il ya un consensus autour de
cette table je vais pas le briser
on voit bien ça le débat a manifestement
mais au cas où cette table on voit bien
en tout cas que la décision finlandaise
ouvre la voie à une évolution à traîne
très importante et et que les autres
élargissement les précédents
élargissements de l'otan n'avait
peut-être pas c'est dire que là on avait
des 7 et 10 des états qui venaient en
définitive s'adosser à la défense
européenne et américaine pour chercher
des garanties de sécurité
là on est en train de devait toucher des
pays qui ont des capacités militaires
propre et qui de surcroît
avait parfois une représentation de même
qui va être percutés par le fait d'aller
intégrer cette alliance militaire donc
on est vraiment sur quelque chose qui
pour moi est plus substantiel plus une
évolution plus radical que les
précédents d'élargissement de l'otan
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous ce sera le mot de la fin merci
marie hollow penan d'avoir été avec nous
en direct de helsinki député finlandaise
de la libraire merci beaucoup crié
schmitt merci cyril coulet merci à vous
amiral l'amiral alain kohl deux filles
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
et bien sûr vous réagissez toujours sur
les réseaux sociaux vous pouvez
retrouver l'émission d'ailleurs dans un
podcast puisque nous sommes aussi en
podcast le débat france 24 et puis sur
notre site internet
www.transat.com
[Musique]
il